yesterday on breakfast we asked why more
than a hundred thousand tons of
contaminated recycling ended up in
landfill last year lots of people
getting touched to say you found sorting
through your rubbish much too
complicated so today we're trying to
find out what could make it easier we
really are one of the biggest problems
seemed to be that people weren't sure
what could and couldn't be recycled and
earlier when we spoke to the local
government minister brandon lewis
even he seemed confused
where you live and i'm not quite sure
where there is can you put yogurt pots
in your recycling
yes we can actually do you know that for
sure i mean i'm not trying to catch you
out it's just that's the the
practicalities are the things that
trouble people most and you know that
for sure do you know absolutely you can
put yogurt pots but butter containers
for example the different types of
plastic you know which one you can and
which one you can't for your own area
yes and to be fair my council which is
great yarmouth are pretty good at
educating people and making people very
clear about what they can and can't
recycle
he has though since then acknowledged on
twitter that he made a mistake and
that's actually hello here we are he got
mixed up he got yogurt pots mixed up
with plastic bottles he says that his
wife corrected him this morning
it is clearly a confusing issue for
everyone including ministers uh we've
been to rochdale to ask people what
would make them recycle more
i think if people had access to a lot
more information on recycling and which
products goes in which bin and stuff
like that everyone would be more
encouraged to do it and they won't be
scared of doing it in case of getting it
wrong and in case of getting a fine for
it if there were a better bin for the
paper because at the minute if you put
the paper in if it's a nice day and it's
windy the paper's just gonna blow away
she's just gonna cause more waste on the
streets if it's easy to do for people
then i think they will do it if they'd
have to put themselves out too much
i think people will do it education
mainly just letting people be aware of
um what they can recycle and how they
can recycle
and i don't think there's enough of that
i think as an incentive probably money
off council tax or money for recycling
that obviously would um
make people recycle more
so many suggestions let's try to sort of
get a bit of clarity for us shall we
phil barton is from the keep britain
tidy and uh richard evans is from
rochford council which is number one
english council for recycling
congratulations on that thank you good
morning both thanks very much um for
joining us we spoke to a minister
earlier and charlie asked him whether or
not yogurt pots could be recycled he
thought they could be and it turns out
they're not how many people are confused
and i think that we've done a lot of
work on on understanding with the public
on what they understand to be the uh
issues and and the lack of clarity is
one of the main ones people are confused
different councils uh have different
collection systems uh there are
different colors to bins you know
they're all together there is a lot of
confusion around and what people want is
to have it clearly explain to them what
they can and can't do why they should be
doing it and what happens to the product
because there's a lot of distrust about
what happens when things are recycled
and we all know there are problems with
contamination of bins which means that
then stuff can't be properly recycled
and so on so it's a complex issue and it
needs clarity and it needs some
leadership i think so richard you're the
success story here we are you're the
ones who are getting it right so um
what's your blueprint for if you like
the kind of yogurt pot conundrum how do
you get people to understand what they
can and cannot do i think in a word it's
simplicity you need a simple scheme that
people can understand and as far as
we're concerned the success is all about
the communications so outside homes in
rochdale rochefort
sorry
yes what is what is there why is it
simpler than it is elsewhere well we we
put some effort in at the beginning i
mean as our start was basically back in
2008 we were on a 19.4 recycling rate
which was pretty poor one of the worst
in essex but there was a decision made
then that we should do something about
it there was a collection of the largest
bin on a weekly basis it was very easy
just residents put the rubbish in the
bin it was taken away and
we were disposing of in the order of
2100 tons in landfill every month every
month so can i be clear were you asking
people to do a lot of separating out
themselves because that seems to be one
of the areas because people get caught
out yes that's right at that stage when
we were on the 19.4 there was a very
modest blue bin that we collected some
glass and plastics in so and paper but
as you say when when you look at it and
think well this isn't a simple scheme
you know you've got some authorities out
there with a multitude of different bins
collected on different weeks collected
on different frequencies so the simple
scheme that we've introduced in rochford
now is basically around three bins the
largest bin is the recycling bin and a
240 liter bin so the message immediately
to the public is that we're taking away
your largest bin that's recycling one of
the smaller bins is basically the
non-recyclables that's collected
fortnightly and not weekly
we do remove the the food and the garden
waste in one bin and that's removed on a
weekly basis right but it is all about
the the simplicity of the scheme um i
just want to talk about financials as
well because people are interested in
that so so they don't they have to sort
into three things but they don't have to
sort the plastic from the paper so that
all goes in one bit absolutely you then
sort that and do you make money out of
what you sort it into
well we don't actually sort that we
contract that right but yes down the
line absolutely dry recycling it's it's
called co-mingled basically it's the mix
of dry recycling we we give we sell that
to a company they basically split it out
into various waste streams the main
interest they have is what is paper
that's where the money is you see phil
it's interesting listening to richard's
blueprint there it doesn't sound that
that difficult does it mean you must be
confounded though
so with with or do you respect rockford
rural areas have better recycling rates
than urban ones we've been particularly
looking at urban authorities who have
much greater difficulties lack of space
high-rise flats
high turnover of populations so that
people don't actually know what they're
supposed to be doing or what the bins
mean and so on
it is basically simple but we've made it
complicated and i i think one of the the
big challenges we have as a country is
how to on the on the one hand explain
clearly to up to the public what what
they should be doing and why and that's
partly because we have different systems
in different parts of the country and
then i think you know we do need to
explore once they once they are
understand what they're doing how best
we could help to incentivize and what we
know from our work is that people would
love to see rewards going back to the
community in terms of better parks or
playgrounds or even as somebody said on
your uh your piece just now uh a um
having some of their council attacks
rebated back if they saves the council
money or running out of time rochefort
council what do they spend the money
they make on it but or do you have any
in the end just really quickly yeah i
mean basically it is about making the
scheme as sharp as we can make it you
know we work very closely with the
contractors sita and we rely
upon them to carry the messages through
to the residents as well but it's it's
all about just trying to make the
schemers simple people don't want to
think about their bins all the time they
just want it taken away you know what uh
we may not want to think about them but
we like talking about them everybody's
absolutely fascinated thank you